so you had palar alessandra from on the
page yeah critique your script yeah
where was it lapse two yes two okay um
so she did as well with season one oh
she did okay yeah and I knew you really
liked the notes that she gave you yeah
what was it about the notes that were so
helpful she heard notes are really I i
I've been using her as a script
consultant for since two thousand nine
hours ago and she's very she gets it
because she knew what I was doing with
last season one that she she knew the
kind of marketing I was trying to go for
she really picked it apart some of the
chances that I took in the writing is
she called them out I was like you
should really reconsider this for the
most part she like I wish I should show
you the notes but it's not like there
was a whole lot of picking apart she
loved the season overall and if she
loves it I know that she's not be essing
me so these little small things that she
was picking out they really I feel like
they're they're true and honest and it's
something I really need to change the
big thing was the ending she didn't like
the ending well because it's it's too
it's it's not Hollywood enough it's not
Hollywood I like it personally on a
creative standpoint because it made me
feel something like I told Chad avi
actually we were having a web a
teleconference or something one like
skype or something all three of us and I
was reading the final pages while we're
all together and I just I let out an
audible sound because of how it hit me I
was like oh wow you know I just saying
really it made me feel something and I
like that I like that better than let's
just tie it up in a pretty bow so cuz
that's it felt real it's really when it
comes down to for me his ending felt
real and also you know opens up for
season three but I mean that that works
too but really the big thing is
it left me feeling something and you
know you can leave feeling warm and
fuzzy but you're not gonna remember warm
and fuzzy you're going to remember
something that's a little bit more
visceral that's that's what I what
good's the ending his first season two
is taking a chance yeah and I knew that
writing it and she she looked at that
was like she would rather me play it
safe so that I can possibly get work out
of it kind of thing where I could be
hired on a show to write for you know
ABC or NBC or whatever you know thanks
you she thinks of it in that in that way
and I and I love that but it's also like
an artistic license of do I do that so
if you guys just take this chance with
this engine because it's very wrong I
feel like love anything is very
different yes I mean it's I mean he
doesn't grow you know they're gonna
amputate alarm it's nothing crazy yeah
it's just it's real that's what it is
it's sort of like you see the course of
action throughout the entire term of the
story that is the only ending that makes
sense that's it like unless you're gonna
do a deus ex machina and then suddenly
make a huge internal shift it doesn't
make sense like this and he makes sense
to me no offense to anybody contrary but
that's how I feel I like the ending so
but my history with pallar is that my
first spec feature script she read back
in 2009 and she was like she gave me
notes on it she told me that this was
you need to send us into the nickel
fellowship and I was like it's an action
film I didn't think that the nickel
fellowship would you know but she's like
no you gotta submits it's that good and
I'm like all right you know like I i can
write something but I'm not gonna be
cocky enough to be like hey this is you
know it's an and so I took her advice I
did the notes and I sent another nickel
fellowship and I made the quarterfinals
like that was I saw it I have I know
that her advice is there's something to
it
i would say shoot to it nixa what's up
shoot two endings I know I haven't I
have a backup anything I guess do
testing audience testing there we go see
ya then search crew I'm gonna do the
amputated he's gonna do the 197 hours
later thing
you